[Musique]
merci réy ferud de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes sénateur socialiste de Paris membre
de la commission des finances on va
évidemment parler du budget dans
quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité on l'a vu dans le journal
c'est cette libération hier de trois
enfants français libérés par le Hamas
ils font partie des 11 otages libérés
hier qu'avez-vous ressenti à la vue de
ces images et de ces enfants français il
y a à la fois du soulagement euh du
bonheur pour ces trois enfants otage
leur famille leurs proches et puis aussi
beaucoup
d'inquiétude pour les autres aotage dont
nos compatriotes et puis de la colère de
voir cette organisation terroriste
islamiste utiliser les otages comme une
monnaie d'échange un objet de chantage
pour se protéger pouvoir poursuivre ces
activités terroristes mais la priorité
doit être mise sur la libération des
otages et je me réjouis que trois
premiers otages français pu pu être
libérés bien sûr c'est un succès de la
diplomatie française en tout cas je vois
que la diplomatie française se mobilise
comme les autres diplomaties et que des
otages français puissent être aussi
libéré est un soulagement bien sûr une
autre actualité on l'a vu là encore dans
le journal c'est Olivier verérrant qui
était hier à crépole pour rencontrer
notamment la famille de Thomas ce jeune
de 16 ans qui a été tué il y a 10 jours
Olivier Verron qui a dit que c'est un
drame qui nous fait courir le risque
d'un basculement de notre société vous
partagez ces mots je ne l'exprimerai pas
comme cela c'est un drame c'est un crime
et je veux aussi saluer les forces de
police qui ont très vite arrêté les
mises en cause il faut maintenant
laisser la police et la justice faire
leur travail mais il faut saluer aussi
la très grande dignité des Français dans
leur ensemble dans cette période très
troublée très difficile et dénoncer les
manipulations de l'extrême droite qui
essaye de transformer un drame en un
moment politique qui lui bénéficie
contre d'ailleurs la volonté des
familles on l'avait déjà vu avec la
petite Lola qui avait été tué à Paris
donc il faut vraiment saluer la dignité
des Français et dénoncer avec force et
aussi intervenir lorsqu'il y a des
nervies d'extrême droite qui viennent
défiler dans les rues que ce soit à
roman suriser ou euh plus récemment je
crois que c'était hier soir à Rennes à
Lyon là nous comptons sur le
gouvernement moi je veux vraiment euh
remarquer la différence entre la dignité
du peuple français sa lucidité euh son
ses convictions républicaines aussi et
puis une extrême droite qui essaie en
effet de faire basculer les choses mais
je crois en la force de la République
Olivier Verant il dit risque de
basculement de la société si nous ne
sommes pas à la hauteur que doit faire
la classe politique que peut-elle faire
pour éviter ce basculement je crois
qu'elle doit donner à la police et à la
justice les moyens de bien travailler
est pas suffisamment le cas puisquon on
va parler du budget ce sont des budgets
qui sont en hausse il y a une remontée
en puissance mais enfin on part de loin
il faut affirmer les valeurs
républicaines il faut aussi lutter
contre les inégalités donner plus de
moyens aux quartiers populaires soutenir
les associations IR l'école de la
République tout cela en effet demande
des moyens
et aussi une fermeté républicaine à tout
moment il ne faut pas jouer avec
l'extrême droite et donc le président de
la qui joue avec l'extrême droite
aujourd'i tout le monde enfin beaucoup
de monde aujourd'hui que ce soit dans
les médias ou dans la classe politique
on le voit exécutif pour vous
ça arrive que il y ait de la confusion
mais chaque fois fois que le
gouvernement sera là pour défendre les
valeurs républicaines je crois que les
socialistes répondront présent on l'a
montré d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours
dans la grande manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme je veux aussi saluer que
c'est ça la force de la France c'est ça
la force de la République on va parler
du budget puisque le Sénat poursuit
l'examen de ce budget on va faire le
point sur les dernières heures de séance
et les mesures qui ont été votées avec
notre journaliste parlementaire audre
vetaz
bonjour Audrey bonjour bonjour monsie FR
et Audrey le Sénat étudie donc en ce
moment la partie recette du budget 2024
avec des mesures qui touchent
directement le quotidien des Français
oui et notamment en matière d'énergie
vous le savez dans un contexte
d'explosion des prix des énergies
notamment lié à la guerre en Ukraine et
à ses conséquences l'an dernier le
gouvernement a mis en place un bouclier
tarifaire c'était une mesure d'urgence
aujourd'hui l'exécutif veut revenir à la
normale sur le papier l'augmentation du
prix de l'électricité devrait donc être
de 20 % à partir du 1er février prochain
ça représente quand même 260 € de plus
en moyenne par an pour les ménages alors
le gouvernement proposait de laisser un
bouclier tarifaire pour que cette hausse
soit limitée à 10 % et qu'elle soit plus
acceptable pour les ménages le Sénat en
a décidé hier autrement avec une
proposition des républicains qui a été
adoptée elle a été jugée plus ciblée en
clair on garde de la hausse de 20 % mais
on donne des chèqus aux ménages les plus
fragiles jusqu'aux classes moyenne ça
permet de compenser la hausse pour 60 %
des ménages français écoutez le
rapporteur ceux des Français qui ont les
revenus les plus élevés et bien ils
n'auront pas d'aide et quand je dis ils
n'auront pas d'aide c'est parce que nous
avons des choix à faire chacun peut
faire ses arbitrages les ménages les
plus modestes souvent n'ont pas de choix
qu'ils soi propriétaire ou locataire et
vous le savez parce que finalement il
cumule des situations difficiles passoir
thermique précarité économique et
souvent sociale là on doit mettre
l'accent le plus important et dans les
ménages chez les ménages les plus aisés
ça relève plus de l'arbitrage personnel
en clair on évite une aide qui bénéficie
à tous et donc au plus aisés ben
figurez-vous que l'idée a été soutenue
par une partie de la gauche par les
écologistes écoutez c'est un amendement
intéressant qui distingue euh les
ménages précaires les classes moyennes
et les et les plus riches a presque
tendance a que c'est un amendement un
peu de gauche donc nous allons le
soutenir les écologistes qui ont donc
voté la mesure estiment que cela
incitera les ménages les plus aisés à
entreprendre des travaux de rénovation
énergétique ce qui est pas vraiment fait
pour l'instant Rémy Ferro le groupe
socialiste n'a pas voté cet amendement
il est pas de gauche il est un peu
gauche j'ai entendu euh il aurait fallu
aller au bout du raisonnement et donc
faire que les ménages les plus aisés
n'est plus cette aide mais doubler
l'aide au ménag les moins aisés ça n'est
pas ce qu'a fait la droite sénatoriale
elle a fait une mesure d'économie
budgétaire en
transformant voilà en transformant le
bouclier tarifaire en un chèque énergie
VO dont la distribution peut être
complexe nous nous sommes reconnus ni
dans ce que proposait le gouvernement ni
dans l'alternative proposée par la
majorité sénatoriale parce que nous
estimons de toute façon que ça n'est
plus le sujet aujourd'hui le sujet c'est
les modalités de tarification de
l'électricité et l'impossibilité pour
les Français de bénéficier du coût de
production en France qui est bien
inférieur cette question du bouclier
tarifaire était vraiment l'enjeu de
l'année dernière cette année le
gouvernement maintient une disposition
qui est imparfaite la droite sénatoriale
prop proposer une autre disposition
toute aussi imparfaite nous ne sommes
pas rentrés tête baissée dans ce débat
en effet comme cela c'est vraiment les
modalités de tarification aujourd'hui
qui doivent nous préoccuper puisqu'on
évoque les mesures qui touchent au
porortemonel des Français les sénateurs
ont voté l'abaissement de la TVA dans
certains territoires d'outreamè oui sur
les produits alimentaires et d'hygiène
ça concerne la Guadeloupe la Martinique
et la Réunion les prix ils sont
structurellement plus élevés résultat 24
% de la population vit en de en
situation de grande pauvreté contre 3 %
sur l'ensemble du territoire français
l'objectif c'est donc de baisser encore
plus la TVA elle est à 2,1 %, les
sénateurs ont proposé de la ramener à
1,5 % sur les produit de première
nécessité on peut dire que c'est un
symbole parce que la mesure a été votée
contre l'avis de la commission contre
l'avis du gouvernement à la peu de
chance de figurer dans le texte final
vous le regrettez que c'est peu de
oui parce que là où nous interpellons le
gouvernement c'est sur les grandes
difficultés de pouvoir d'achat des
Français les plus modeste et c'est
particulièrement le cas en outremè où
les prix sont plus élevés où les
habitants sont plus pauvres et peut-être
que la TVA n'est pas la mesure la plus
idéale parce que elle est parfois
récupérée dans les marges et cetera mais
ça montre la préoccupation du Sénat pour
les outresmèes et pour nos compatriotes
qui sont confrontés à l'inflation et aux
économique et sociale et donc je
regretterai que le gouvernement n'en
tienne pas compte si c'est le cas mais
je crains que ce soit malheureusement
malheureusement le cas autre mesure sur
le pouvoir d'achat en tout cas sur le
porte-monnaie le Sénat a adopté malgré
quelques réticences une nouvelle taxe
visant les concessions autoroutières et
les grands aéroports une contribution
qui doit notamment financer le
développement du ferroviaire et
l'entretien des voiries des
collectivités alors une question est-ce
qu'on ne risque pas nous consommateurs
de voir un impact sur le prix des
billets par exemple ou sur le prix du
péage autoroutier j'espère que non en
tout cas sur les péages autoroutiers
c'est même ce que nous a dit le
gouvernement euh mais je me réjouis que
cette mesure soit inscrite dans le
projet de loi de finance on peut aussi
aller plus loin c'est aussi dû aux
travaux du Sénat la mission d'enquête
sur les autoroutes donc il faudra être
vigilant en effet sur les tarifs des
péages autoroutiers mais j'ai entendu
l'engagement du ministre qui disait que
ça n'urait pas d'impact autre mesure qui
concerne le quotidien des Français le
Sénat impose une TVA aux location de
meublé touristique et ça vous concerne
en tant que sénateur de Paris deuxème
coup de semonce de la chambre haute hier
contre ces locations qui compliquent le
marché dans les secteurs très tendus ce
weekend le Sénat a diminué l'abattement
sur les revenus de ses hébergements en
zone de sousension locative hier il a
imposé une TVA avec un amendement qui
était porté par le LR Marc Brisson et le
communiste Yann brossa tous deux c'est
sénateur de zone en tenstion concerné
par ce type de location garit et Paris
écoutez la raison c'est d'essayer de
faire disparaître cette distorsion de
concurrence qui aujourd'hui pèse
beaucoup sur les hôteliers par rapport
aujourd'hui à des résidences qui sont
peu à peu transformé en location
saisonnière qui s'apparentent à des
hôtels sans les contraintes ni fiscales
ni de normes de l'hôtel c'est bien là
mon combat mon combat c'est est pas
rapport à ceux qui dans des cités
touristiques achètent peu à peu des
immeubles tout entiers les transforment
en hôtel de fit et ne sont ni à sujetti
à la TVA ni à respecter les normes de la
TVA un combat qui fait donc consensus à
gauche et à droite clairement c'est la
plateforme Airbnb qui est visé
l'objectif c'est de la soumettre à la
TVA comme c'est déjà le cas pour les
hôtels pour éviter les distorsions de
concurrence alors vous qui êtes sénateur
de Paris donc concerné par ces locations
rirbnb est-ce que ces mesures suffisent
est-ce qu'il faut un un projet de loi un
texte de loi sur C ces mesures ne
suffiront pas mais elles sont absolument
indispensables il y a euh le fait
d'aligner la TVA euh ce que nous avions
voté aussi pendant le weekend et qui est
encore plus important c'est-à-dire de
faire en sorte que pour la déclaration
impôt sur le revenu il n'y ait pas
davantage donné au fait que vous louyiez
votre appartement en location
touristique saisonnière plutôt que de le
louer sur le long terme à des vrais euh
habitants euh il y a d'autres mesures
fiscales qui avaient été proposées qui
n'ont pas été retenu par exemple si vous
louez un appartement en location
touristique saisonnière et vous payez
l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière et
bien cet appartement ne fait pas partie
du patrimoine qui est taxé donc tout est
fait aujourd'hui dans la fiscalité pour
donner un avantage aux locations
touristiqu et donc pour alimenter la
crise du logement ça fait longtemps que
les élus parisiens nous interpellons le
gouvernement mais aussi
la majorité sénatoriale sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui cette crise du logement elle
n'existe pas seulement à Paris elle
existe dans tous les territoires tendu
c'est-à-dire dans de plus en plus de
départements français et je me réjouis
qu'évidemment que le Sénat ait voté et
émis ces votes là dans la discussion
budgétaire j'espère que le gouvernement
va garder ses dispositions il a dit
qu'il ne le souhaitait pas euh j'espère
qu'il va changer d'avis et que si ce
n'était pas le cas une loi sur justement
l'encadrement des locations saisonnières
va venir très vite et aussi frapper fort
pour ne plus leur donner l'avantage
qu'elles ont aujourd'hui si vous êtes
propriétaire aujourd'hui vous avez
davantage intérêt à le louer en location
saisonnière ça n'est plus possible de
continuer comme ça c'est une distorsion
de concurrence pour l'hôtellerie mais
c'est aussi et plus dramatiquement un
élément important de la crise du
logement en France qui fait que beaucoup
de Français ont du mal à accéder au
logement l'argument de l'exécutif c'est
de dire que ce type de location permet
de développer le tourisme dans les zones
justement très peu touristiques oui
d'accord mais alors dans ce cas-là il
faut s'adapter à la décentralisation il
y a des secteurs où cela vient alimenter
une économie locale de manière favorable
et d'autres où ça vient au contraire
créer une crise sociale très grave je
crois que même le gouvernement n'utilise
plus en réalité cet argument
aujourd'hui ce qu'il a toujours refusé
jusqu'à présent c'est de permettre au
maires d'avoir beaucoup plus la libre
les mains libres et au conseils
municipaux pour décider de la
réglementation sur ces locations donc
s'adapte à la décentralisation c'est
faire une fiscalité local sur ce type de
bien c'est ça non
c'estalité nationale et de donner au
Mair la capacité d'interdire d'autoriser
aujourd'hui tout dépend de la loi
nationale dans beaucoup d'autres
pays en Europe par exemple en Allemagne
les municipalités peuvent choisir leur
réglementation et la fiscalité par
contre nationalement doit être modifié
pour rétablir de de l'égalité et pas
favoriser les locations saisonnières par
rapport aux locations longue durée un
dernier mot plus largement sur ce budget
16 milliards d'économie affiche le
gouvernement le Sénat qui veut rajouter
5 milliards d'économies supplémentair la
majorité de la droite et du centre c'est
nécessaire au vu de l'état de nos
finances
publiques de rajouter encore des
économies c'est surtout nécessaire de
rajouter des ressources fiscales
d'arrêter de priver l'état de ressources
donc euh nous nous nous battons contre
toujours ce désarmement fiscal qui
profite toujours au mêmes aux grandes
entreprises et qui touche aujourd'hui
complètement ses limites d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière le gouvernement
le reconnaît puisque il refuse de
renoncer à la suppression de la CVAE une
taxe locale qui pèse sur les entreprises
mais comme c'est beaucoup trop coûteux
il l'étale dans le temps surtout le
kinena alors qu'il voulait le faire dès
le début du du quinquena donc on est un
peu dans des non choix et ceci dit il
nous manque des ressources pour mener
les politiques publiques nécessaires
donc faire des économie c'est bien beau
mais il y a aussi beaucoup de dépenses
indispensables beaucoup
d'investissements indispensables
notamment dans la transition écologique
et le gouvernement ne s'en donne pas les
moyens et là-dessus il y a une
convergence de vue entre la droite
sénatoriale et le gouvernement c'est pas
nouveau on suivra l'examen de ce budget
jusqu'au 12 décembre ici au Sénat merci
audre à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
on va parler de la popularité de
l'exécutif ce sera à suivre dans le club
on va voir l'actualité à Paris en
Île-de-France maintenant on retrouve
Jacques Paquier directeur de la
rédaction du journal du Grand Paris
bonjour Jacques merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Jacques pour commencer vous
allez revenir sur cette polémique entre
anidalgo et Clément bon le ministre des
Transports autour de cette question les
transports seront-ils prêts pour les
Jeux Olympiques
oui le le ton est légèrement monté la
semaine dernière alors que le les Jos
les Jeux Olympiques faisaient l'objet
d'une sorte de consensus jusqu'à présent
tous groupe pour réussir l'événement et
là annidalgo sur le plateau de d'une
chaîne de télévision concurrente a dit
Rémi Ferro vous le savez que on ne
serait peut-être pas prêt évoquant à la
fois la la fréquence le nombre de de
trains qui serait insuffisant et
s'inquiétant de la perspective de de de
de donc du coup de d'impréparation ce à
quoi Clément bone quelques jours plus
tard je crois que c'était sur RTL lui a
répondu en qualifiant ses propos de
honteux tout simplement estimant je cite
qu'idalgo paradait sur les plateaux télé
pour faire oublier ces turpitudes euh
que lui
répondez-vous Clément bun
euh tape facilement sur la mer de Paris
puis là il est très susceptible donc
annidalgo a dit l'autre jour la vérité
elle a mis deux points d'alerte sur
l'organisation des Jos les transports
publics tous les parisiens tous les
Franciliens peuvent le dire aussi parce
que par qu'ils prennent les transports
tous les jours et il voient les
difficultés et l'hébergement des
sansabriis pendant la période des Jeux
Olympiques elle est dans son rôle
d'alerter sur les difficultés
d'organisation ça aurait même été une
erreur de ne pas le faire à un moment
elle l'a
fait de manière d'ailleurs à dire il
faut qu'on travaille ensemble qu'on
trouve des solutions donc euh et puis
l'actualité y compris de ce matin sur le
prix des transports publque pendant les
Jeux Olympiques montre qu'elle a raison
en tout cas je vois qu'elle a réveillé
le gouvernement euh l'exécutif de la
région île-de-fance et je pense qu'elle
a bien fait parce que elle avait raison
de dire cela là monsieur le sénateur
vous pensez que c'est une question de
moyen on parle souvent du financement
des transports en Île-de-France vous le
savez avec les polémiques sur le le le
le le le niveau du prix du du Pass
Navigo qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour qu'on soit bien prêt il faut
accélérer les travaux qui do doivent
être finis avant les Jeux Olympiques il
faut recruter des personnels il faut
donner les moyens financiers au
transport public en Île-de-France et
c'est une responsabilité partagée de la
région Île-de-France et du gouvernement
ça fait quand même des années que on
n'investit pas assez dans les transports
publics il y avait même des perspectives
de privatisation de ligne qui ont créé
beaucoup de découragement et la RATP il
faut voter une loi en urgence pour
reporter ces perspectives de
privatisation et ça faisait des années
que la gauche nous alertion donc il y a
des difficultés lourdes dans les
transports publics en Île-de-France il
faut absolument remonter la pente avant
les Jeux Olympiques c'est cela qu'a dit
annidalgo et elle avait raison de le
dire elle était dans son rôle alors JAC
paquy a parlé de Clément bon mais il y a
aussi améliie oua Castera la ministre
des Sports qui s'en prend à anidalgo qui
dit s'il faut livrer des jeux sans elle
on le fera et s'il faut les livrer
malgré elle on le fera donc vous voyez
la mère de Paris dit quelles sont les
difficultés dans la préparation des Jos
et tout le gouvernement per son son sans
froid je raaris à ministre des sport que
c'est Anne hiidalgo euh qui s'est battu
pour avoir les gios et faire les Jeux
Olympiques sans Paris ou sans la mer de
Paris moi je pense qu'il faut que les
ministres se se ressaisisse on Jacques
on a dit un mot mais Valérie PC a
annoncé hier le doublement quasi
doublement du prix du ticket de métro
cet été pendant les J pour compenser et
financer le surcût des transports liés à
ces Jeux Olympiques qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette annonce que c'est les
conséquences de contraintes budgétaires
insolubles et que c'est très dommage de
ne pas faire de ce moment des Jeux
Olympiques un moment qui
favorise les transports en commun et les
déplacements en transport en commun au
maximum donc mais dommage de la part de
kit Val PC qui annonce le doublement du
prix ou du gouvernement qui n'aide pas
suffisamment la région pour éviter le
doublement de ce prix des deux des deux
mais parfois le gouvernement ça TS à
faute des collectivités locales la
réalité on le voit dans tous les
territoires c'est que les difficultés
des transports publics sont dues à un
sous-investissement et au manque de
moyens qui sont donnés par le
gouvernement depuis longtemps pour
financer justement le développement des
transports publics alors que c'est un
des enjeux essentiels de la transition
écologique du pays et que voilà c'est
jamais assez c'est jamais suffisamment
tôt et on le voit on le voit bien
aujourd'hui en île-de-fance Jacques vous
avez une autre question sur la
limitation de la vitesse sur le
périf absolument autre sujet passionnel
si j'ose dire on le sait le périf la
vitesse sur le périf donc elle est passé
de 80 à 70 et là il est prévu il est
annoncé qu'elle va passer qu'elle
passerait à à 50 kmh c'est une des
mesures du plan climat que la mairie de
Paris a a récemment annoncé c'est à la
fois pour faire baisser monsieur Ferro
la pollution atmosphérique on le sait la
pollution de l'air qui qui provoque des
morts en nombre tout à fait stupéfiant
mais c'est aussi pour on le sait moins
pour faire baisser la pollution
sonore pourquoi estimez-vous Rémi Ferro
qu'il s'agit en l'occurrence d'une
mesure justifiée mais pour les raisons
que vous avez dites diminuer la
pollution diminuer les
difficultés pour les riverins du
périphérique ce sont plusieurs centaines
de milliers de d'habitants à Paris et
dans les commune rivraen du
périphérique c'est une mesure qui était
dans notre programme en 2020 c'est une
mesure qui a été proposée par une
mission du Conseil de Paris de manière
très transpartisane en 2019 et donc il
faut après les Jeux Olympiques qu'il y
ait un bénéfice éc olique aussi des Jeux
Olympiques et donc baisser la vitesse
sur le périphérique ce qui amorcera la
dimension de boulevard urbain nous
voulons sortir de cette dimension
autoroutière et puis garder une voix de
covoiturage je trouve ça hallucinant que
et la droite et le gouvernement soit
comme ça si réticent à garder cette
dimension de covoiturage et à
passer à un boulevard urbain j'ai
entendu justement Clément BR il trouv la
mesure était brutale moi je pense que
c'est quand même beaucoup bien
avavantage la pollution le dérèglements
climatiques qui sont brutaux avec ce
genre de raisonnement qui renvoie
toujours à plus tard et bien on va pas
on va pas y arriver donc euh oui il
faudra passer à 50 km/h sur le
périphérique pour sortir de l'autoroute
et rentrer dans une dimension d'un
boulevard urbain ça n'empêche pas de
circuler ça empêchera de polluer
davantage ça empêche êchera de faire
beaucoup de bruit et on passera enfin à
une nouvelle étape de la métropole
parisienne merci Jacques Paquier merci
c'est David lnard à la Une du journal du
Grand Paris le président de
l'Association des maires de France
décentralisation aménagement finance les
propositions des ma c'est à la Une de
votre journal cette semaine merci
beaucoup Jacques Paquier un petit mot de
politique pour terminer Rémi Ferro
puisque le PRG le Parti radical de
gauche a annoncé qu'il aurait sa propre
liste aux Européennes soutenu par
Bernard casenu est-ce que c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour le parti
socialiste en tout cas ça doit
l'interpeller et moi je souhaite que
dans la préparation des élections
européennes travaille à rassembler la
famille socialiste républicaine
européenne de gauche parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut enfin
pouvoir
reconstruire une gauche républicaine
autour du Parti socialiste qui puisse
discuter REM j ça veut dire vous espérez
que le PRG finisse par V rallier et
avoir une gr commune oui mais encore
faut-il le lui proposer faut lui tendre
la main le PRG la convention de Bernard
Caseneuve euh la gauche républicaine et
socialiste Emmanuel Morel qui est député
européen sortant tous les socialistes je
crois qu'il y a une attente et c'est
notre responsabilité de le faire
derrière Raphaël gluxman qui n'est pas
socialiste pourquoi pas pourquoi pas ça
n'est pas une décision qui est prise
mais pourquoi pas merci REM Cheron